hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play gray okay
I got batteries in here I don't know
what else is there but I gotta go back
to the darkness
I like that so little that is the worst
I swear nothing happened like thought
things were gonna happen there's nothing
in here nothing in here let me out now
what was with the wood breaking exit why
don't does like I found the way out no
that's a lie that's a lie
Simon I closed the building for the
working hours
I don't want strangers walking around if
you want to leaves for something the key
is on the top of my locker the character
wears his locker
oh no I gotta go back through the
darkness oh no I didn't even know where
I came in from oh in there that's right
oh I hate this I hate this so much
oh oh what's going on uh uh ah text I
swear gosh it's gonna be the death of me
I aah
oh is that Slendy oh it's not okay good
King Elvis Ted okay all right so top of
the locker
toughy tough top tip top top top top
okay god rock-cut can do this bring it
on bring it on bring it on bring it on
bring it on bring it on
step into the windmill of death who's
gonna get bombed the plunk mill of death
right Oh want some oh you don't
that's right back off Oh can't handle
not longitude give me while I just
mashed that that's one button
hahaha okay
the cluster of imposing masonry in dark
alleyways finally gave way the familiar
lights of the city at the kitchen my
breath I instinctively began walking
towards work I was looking for help
lacking any other options even in the
brighter lights of the streets shadows
seemed to be creeping around the edge of
my vision my imagination turning them
into horrific distortions of
otherworldly Menace I fell hemmed in as
if something were directing me down a
path that I did not necessarily want to
tread yeah no joke
basically there's been no monsters or
anything to actually scare me it's just
been me scary myself okay why am i no
more ducts or dust of rooms
yeah that's what you think Simon that is
not the way it'd be in these types of
games and I know that it'd be very very
disturbing
poor Big Ben nothing save big nothing
big bunk bunk ok nothing I'm doing the
xplory thing and all that be vanity
guess I could have just gone through the
entrance there but ha ha who does that a
big bo-boogie
unnhhh ammo ammo for shooty bang bang
when i get one of those things I mean I
haven't even haven't think the single
thing to kill but I've just been very
very very desirous to have a gun be nice
they still don't have like a limited
inventory I don't think save I can't
tell what is it like snowing ash oh
those are leaves nevermind I'm an idiot
I ignore me I'm a giant giant giant
leave what was that what was that what
was that what was that what was that was
aa
step into the bog meal oh no one can
handle the Blanc mil no no no no no I
don't even know where I'm going I'm just
going with like a circle slopped an open
ten blocks has got dawn ah lamplights
how do I see where I've got batteries
all right ten minute walking them there
yeah yeah that's totally what's gonna
happen man
oh there I can open it nothing has hurt
me so far besides that miniscule fall
what the [ __ ] was that oh we almost got
it in the bog Phil you go get bone Oh
I don't wanna I don't wanna
alright I'm tougher than this I'm just
being scared by my own shadow now it's
so weird because as soon as things
actually start to attack me it's gonna
get a lot less scary it's just so weird
it is you know working oh I mean the
capability to kill your enemies huh oh
no oh it's like a hedge oh nevermind I'm
never gonna talk about it we're not
gonna say anything about that
nothing nothing about that good golly
why do I keep going in these buildings
why why why
is loud from down oh those are not a
door
got a little 8 minutes alright I'm gonna
stop being a big baby now get down to
brass tacks
I got a bunker what ha ha ha oh ok get
away from Brad huh what oh ha ha ha cuz
you're a [ __ ] or maybe not maybe you're
nice I don't know Oh
no no no no no no no the sense of relief
at reaching work never came another no
was waiting for me drenching me with a
taste of dread I can't read that the
handwriting again seemed to almost
dislodge something from my memory it was
clearly from the same author again the
message was brief but this time it held
in an intimate message go home the
quickest way back would be through the
decaying homeless shelter the subway
waiting on the other side
wanting save time I set out should you
be worried about that thing that just
happened you know okay there you are
yeah it's um yeah that was bad oh it's
quiet I was really quiet locked oh it's
too quiet
I finally made it did you did you dearly
doubt that oh yeah he made it to work
the I guess it text is like a little bit
ahead of itself the loading screen you
know impose a little ah
a gun a boom banger where is it this is
arrow that no come Tobruk him - okay um
what was the point of going down there
Oh in here okay stop come home honey
what that we have to talk about this
this is my mother's handwriting it
couldn't be her I don't have a choice
though I have to follow it really why
why do you have to follow it isn't it a
little suspicious that there's no one
else in the world because this is how
cry fear happened and Simon you of all
people to know the crop here is bad
first aid stuff I don't know oh they
gave me a gun I know monsters are going
to start clapping okay what do I do
alright what's going on here No
disconcerting he's been acting up in the
last two weeks right good for it now
what you gonna do about that I got a
letter from my dead mother I don't know
what is going on here but I think I
should listen to her
okay all right so why is that flashing
why
oh you came from the bathroom okay you
didn't even wash your hands before you
start stabbing me ooh I might have
wasted a lot of ammo on that
how did turning off the power allow me
to open that I'm just doing wrong it
yeah I've been going to the gym getting
the wool yeah you know you know these
guys don't even know you don't even know
oh yeah ha ha what's now what's going on
bro do you even lift
I almost run myself out of ammo just
dead you bad I do bad things
I believe I panic there but the next one
is going to get bonked okay I'm actually
no I'm not I get more time never mind
Nora I said that well I found some ammo
oh good Oh God
I can't even see my like her name
just flat-out ham oh god this is so
[ __ ] that sounds like something that
Simon would say alright now I am out of
time so thank you all so much for
watching is good bad in here so thank
you all so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next part
bye bye